so I'm going to talk Bob and I sort of
divided the transportation world a
little bit here i'm going to talk
picking up on the theme of the video a
little bit about what's going on with
high-speed rail and then Bob's going to
talk about what's going on with the
federal transportation program and add
more more about highways and stuff but
here's the really the key for for making
this whole session quite easy as the
budget deal that just passed basically
stripped all of high-speed rail funding
all the federal funding for high-speed
rail out of the budget so high speed
rail what was planned is gone and so
that that's it for a speed breath
unfortunately that's not true that's not
it by a long stretch because it's you
know high-speed rails holy and you can't
just walk away from something that's
holy just because there's no money yeah
the thing with highs rail is that I want
to make really clear as high-speed rail
is a great technology it's a great
system I have written a number of
high-speed rail lines around the world
they rock and I think in the future
they're going to be part of the way
people travel in many many parts the
world including the United States the
problem is the way that planners are
using the technology in the United
States it's not the technology it's the
fact that we have really lousy planners
in the United States well their planners
right so the end of letters are abusing
this technology viciously so you have
adult touch as I go along on specific
projects out there but just for example
one of the one of the projects that is
in line was in line for federal funding
and it's still clamoring for federal
funding is a Chicago to st. Louis line
now there's already a on track line that
runs there and it takes the bat trip
takes three hours and 40 minutes I think
right now three hours and 48 minutes
that's what it is and the plan is to
spend two billion dollars to upgrade
that line to high-speed rail which will
knock that trip down to three hours and
18 minutes 2 billion 20 minutes what a
deal oh and that's for say eight eight
or nine thousand people that ride at
each years
Wow their time must be really valuable
so you have a number of the systems that
have been proposed or not really high
speed rail that they're they're slightly
faster speed rail projects like that you
know you're you're essentially adding 15
miles an hour to a train line that runs
you know through couple three states and
you're going to spend billions of
dollars to achieve that so not exactly a
revolutionary now the good news is is
the Missouri legislature which is on the
hook to pay for a substantial chunk of
that project just said hell no and cut
it completely out of their budget as
well so that project is is at least for
now dead the fundamental the fundamental
problem with these high-speed rail plans
in the United States is our issues of
risk now I have an eleven-year-old
daughter who has a strong
entrepreneurial streak she wants to run
her own business really bad and most of
her business ideas are you know it's
it's terrible you're a parent you have
to explain to the kids yeah you don't
want to just say no that's not possible
you know you don't want to rain on their
parade but I mean some of them are
really just not possible okay you always
have a strike that balance but so she's
always trying to come up with these
businesses we home screw our kids so as
they constantly complain it turns out
everything we do somehow ends up
becoming school so they can't ever quite
escape the clutches of that so she did
come up with a business idea and because
everything is school we said well if
you're going to start a business you
know you've got you're going to learn
about how business works so you gonna
have to come up with a business plan you
know a budget projections all this stuff
we're going to loan you the startup
capital you have to pay it back with
interest all of this stuff and so she
did she went through all this and this
business was she was going to buy a
bunch of chicks and raised them and sell
them as laying hens because she learned
through various conversations that there
was a lot of demand for
hands in our community for people who
didn't want to go through the trouble of
blind chicks and raising them up
themselves so she worked it all out she
had a plan she she she sketched it all
out sure if everything worked out
according to her plan she'd make about
two hundred fifty dollars in profit and
so she she launched the business and she
just wrapped this up about a month ago
and had a really bad winter storm deep
snow nine young chickens died in that
storm and a hawk plucked to life right
out of our back your heart Monday and
another one got stuck and kind of wedged
itself under a shed and apparently
couldn't figure out how to get out and
just croaked so so so she had some
attrition and that was in her plan and
so she wound up still making making a
decent profit but not nearly what she
planned and that was because she had no
risk in her plan whatsoever for plan was
entirely based on everything working
exactly right and this is just like
high-speed rail I told a show put you on
the high-speed rail authority on you
know you need beef you'd fit right in
because there's no risk in building
high-speed rail it's all it's all
sunshine and roses in the future we
could build these things and people ride
them and it's you know saves us saves us
from climate change and everybody
everybody drives happy and it's more
communal than driving and so on and so
forth but no these things are fraught
with risk and that was actually the core
of David mentioned at the opening dinner
and it's come up subsequently that you
know Governor Scott in Florida killed
this plan to build a high-speed rail
line from Tampa to Orlando which you
know I mean come on that doesn't mean
pass the laugh test oh yeah it was
passing the spend hundreds of millions
of dollars on it test it that a state
legislature and the federal government
so you know a pair
that wasn't enough money to laugh about
for them but the man was predicated on
the rosiest possible scenarios that no
possible downside no no no way would
people choose the much faster option of
renting a car in Tampa and driving to
orlando rather than somehow getting to
the Tampa station writing to Orlando and
then renting a car there because that's
the only way you can get anywhere
Orlando so it's a one hour trip by the
rental car it's a it's a 49 minute trip
on the high-speed rail line so you can
see why to save that 11 minutes and you
know it would be much better than
renting a car to drive a few miles
instead of it is did it didn't add up
and so we published a report that
essentially broke this down and said
look let's assume a little bit more
reasonable facts about how many people
would actually want to ride the train
from Tampa to Orlando still
extraordinarily generous but just a
little bit more reasonable let's assume
that you won't have this incredible
growth I mean they had they said look if
this train is there what will happen is
people who work in Orlando will start to
buy houses along this high-speed rail
line and then they'll use it to commute
into orlando and we'll get a bunch of
ridership from that never mind the
system wasn't designed to serve that if
you had to stop to pick up all these
writers it wouldn't be a high speed rail
anymore and there was the development
wasn't going that direction you know
there was a few risks there let's just
say no we leave all that out of the plan
and the bottom line was this we we
projected look if everything doesn't go
exactly according to this rosy scenario
plan if some of these risks manifest
that somebody is going to kind of have
to come up with a few hundred million
bucks and who is that according to the
deal that exists who's that going to be
well now this data floor that have been
saying well it's the private sector
that's they're going to invest in this
project and they're going to take that
risk and they'll wind up paying it if it
comes to pass and the private sector
saying those are pretty much guaranteed
losses we don't invest in gear
key losses very often so no no that
wasn't going to happen this idea that
somehow you could privatize the downside
of these projects was embedded in the
state guard which goes to show there
were obviously no business people in the
state legislature in Florida or the
Department of Transportation so that's
and that's what it took to kill it was
we just had to point out look there are
risks we can argue all day about how big
they are but everybody accepts there's
risks that are left out you know once
you point them out and it's the Florida
taxpayers who are going to have to pay
for those risks do you want that and you
know his position from their beginning
is you know unless you can prove to me
that there's no way ever we would have
to spend more money on it I'm not going
to support it and since we can pretty
thoroughly prove that for sure you're
going to have spent more money on this
thing that was that was the deal killer
so move across the country to California
where you have really the one remaining
project out of all the live projects
right now that's high speed so the other
half a dozen or so really viable by a
viable now let's say the other half a
dozen or so projects out there that have
a reasonable chance of sucking up a
bunch of taxpayer money to be built
there all this sort of moving from low
speed rail to slightly less low speed
rail the real you know bullet train
project in California so in California
they want to build this from ultimately
from San Diego to San Francisco with a
branch connecting in Sacramento the
starting phase is the LA to San
Francisco chunk but you still have to
that's a long stretch you still gotta
start building a piece somewhere so
after lengthy negotiations with all the
stakeholder groups the environmentalists
and the landowners in the federal
government who is putting in two and a
half billion dollars up front into this
and the state's got ten billion to get
it started but that's okay it's an 80
billion project this is just the starter
money they just they worked out where
they're going to start building this
line and where they're going to build
the first
this line is from a little town just
north of the massive metropolis of
Bakersfield California up north to a
little town just south of that slightly
more massive metropolis of Fresno
California so the first segment of the
train will literally go from a town of
25,000 to a town of 17,000 and that's
going to be the opening project that's
going to be the champagne bottle busting
or maybe it should be a cow pie either
so you know I mean what could be more
laughable universally people look at
that and just be kidding me but no no if
your allies be real business what do you
not joking about this this is where
because this is the loss leader see the
government has to step in and build this
part where you know private sector can't
make any money between Bakersfield and
Fresno or between not quite Bakersfield
and not quite Fresno because actually
connecting to real cities that would be
crazy no we're going to do that and then
the private sector will jump on and
build the rest of it up to San Francisco
because you know all those 17,000 people
will be riding that train to carry their
pigs to market or something and so we'll
have a base for building the market you
know Jay Leno couldn't even figure out
how to make up something more absurd
than this so it's and the killer the
killer is in when you look at all these
projects and the the thing about high
speed rail and the thing about these
risks is there really locked in risks
you know if you open a new airport if
you build a new road if you you know
build a dam if you know there's a lot of
things you can build that if they don't
work out there's you have alternatives
high-speed rail there's not once you lay
that rail if not enough people write it
there's not a whole lot you can do with
those tracks to you know say well
teether the rail real thing didn't work
out I don't know you know let's uh let's
put those pump handle cars on there and
you know sell it is it as a fitness
center I don't know you know not much
you can do with this thing and you know
you can you can shoot movies on it you
know in California everything always has
that movie set potential but you know if
you if you start an airline between
Bakersfield Fresno you know it's nice
little turboprop planes and that doesn't
work out well you know those planes
there was always gonna be somewhere
where those planes can make money so you
don't have to invest a lot you build a
high-speed rail line there and you're
building something that's going to cost
a fortune and if it doesn't work out you
can't get any of that money back so it's
really locked in risk so it's a it's
there's there's sort of two edges to the
sword you're taking a huge amount of
risk and you got no way to wiggle out of
it should those risks all manifest but
the most then I keep coming back to is I
talked to various groups about high
speed rail is you kind of have to deal
with the fundamental issue of you know
the hope of the future the hope for the
future of travel that high-speed rail
manifest is like if we have this
high-speed rail network when you hear
Joe Biden and President Obama talk about
it you know they have this vision of
high-speed rail connecting all the major
cities of the US and that's the way
people are going to travel now because
because that's what they do in Europe
and Asia so we're literally behind
Europe and Asia so you know it's it's
not a fantasy it's not hope it's we're
looking at the real world
and we're trying to catch up is the
standard story but there's a lot of
things wrong with that Stanford story
first for starters we all traveled
between cities by rail back in the day
so rewind a hundred years and all over
the world intercity travel was by train
that's that was the technology a hundred
years ago in the u.s. in Europe in Asia
everywhere so once upon a time everyone
got between cities by train and then
what happened well there was this world
war two thing and at the end of World
War two for a lot of reasons the u.s.
took a divert a divergent maybe not an
entirely divergent pat but we we took a
path out of pace that was much different
from the rest of the world we started
rolling out we use the the industry that
developed during the war to build cars
and cars became ubiquitous and
affordable we also had an explosion in
the middle class in the post-war period
so we not only had the ability to make
cheap cars we had lots of people who
could afford relatively cheap cars at
the same time and so we did and people
could not wait to get out of those damn
trains and get into a car the trains
were there that was the competition
between trains and cars and people fled
those trains as fast as they could in
order to ride in cars between cities and
the same time you had the you had
airline industry developing and flights
but you know during most of the 50s and
60s flying was strictly something for
the rich so that wasn't the big deal it
was the cars that was the big deal now
in Europe and in Asia they're going
through exactly the same thing just 35
years later you know in in China in
Japan in Australia in all of Europe
people are abandoning rail for cars and
that's in a situation where everybody
road trains in the post-war
period in between cities in Europe and
Asia and as they started building
high-speed rail lines in those country
it was just an upgrade like if you're
riding the train to see grandma three
times a year and they fill up high-speed
train you're going to use the high-speed
train it's just an upgrade in the
service that you have available
especially if it's subsidized and
affordable as all of these systems are
all the high speed rail systems in the
world are subsidized so no brainer they
never never in Europe at any point in
time or in Asia have they tried to get
people to get out of cars and get onto
trains they have built high speed rate
rail lines to get people out of slow
trains and into fast trains now getting
people out of slow trains into fast
trains is kind of a no-brainer getting
people out of cars into trains is a
different proposition but that is
exactly what we propose to do in the
United States it's really a people out
of Southwest and out of their cars and
get them into trains no one in the world
has ever done that so it's an untested
belief and it doesn't I know it doesn't
pass muster it's not in the plans that
exist like in California it's not going
to be faster it's not going to be
cheaper it's not going to be more
convenient it could be cheaper if the
government decides to ridiculously
subsidize it but that's the only way
it's going to be a lot cheaper a way to
travel then you have the sort of the
real killer which is in Europe and Asia
gasoline taxes or three times on average
what they are in the u.s. most of the
major inner-city highways in those
countries are toll roads so people have
to pay more to drive between the cities
and again they have this history they
always use trains to go between cities
now they have the option of faster
trains so if you get that wow it's
massively
more expensive to drive between cities
I've got subsidized high-speed rail to
replace the low speed rail I always use
why would I drive between cities and yet
the growth in Europe in inner-city
travel is in flying and driving not
trains high-speed rail still there is
still popular still carries a lot of
travel but it's not the growing market
share people are increasingly willing to
pay much more in order to drive or to
fly because now it's cheaper and cheaper
to fly so this this whole myth that
somehow Asia and Europe represent a path
that we have not taken is completely
fundamentally wrong in all of its
important details so the last thing I
want to say about this is it it's struck
struck me for a while as really
interesting how much of government
policy yo we all make fun of this right
so everything's for the children you
know that seems to drive so much of
policy these days and and so we have
constant questions of we need to make
these radical investments we need to
curtail our current behavior or current
consumption etc etc you know in order to
be able to you know not undermined our
children's future or in order to elevate
our children's future right one or the
other is for some reason that doesn't
translate into transportation so we have
a system right now that carries oh you
know 98 well 99 percent of all personal
travel it's personal surface travel
which is the highway is not the rail
lines that carries the vast majority of
the goods and that are that are moved
around the country and which we have
been beggaring for 25 years for 25 years
we have been systematically under
spending under maintaining the road
system that carries everybody so we're
you know we're we're deliberately and
systematically undermining the
transportation system that our kid
going to have to use now this idea that
oh well we build a high-speed rail
system at least they would be able to
take a subsidized trip between cities on
this high-speed rail system maybe but
that's not going to help them get get to
work or anything practical like that
anything in day-to-day life so and the
proposal is to take more money away from
the system that we actually use in order
to build this high-speed rail system so
we're even going to accelerate the
deterioration of the system that our
kids are going to have to use to
accomplish this so it's a you know boy
how can we double down on a bad bet here
you know the fundamental trade-off there
is is not explicitly recognized you know
they somehow think we can you know have
our cake and eat it too and I just look
at we did an analysis of 50 largest
cities in the United States and how they
spend their transportation monies in
most of the 50 largest cities in the
United States they are spending between
forty and sixty percent of all spending
all transportation spendings are all
transportation spending is being spent
on the public transit system so that's
the subways and the buses in the light
light rail okay and those systems are in
all of those cities carrying less than
three percent of the people so how long
can you spend fifty percent of your
money on three percent of the market and
expect that to be sustainable to use
their turn well not it's mean we are
that is systematically taking the system
that's caring ninety-seven percent of
the people and letting it fall apart in
order to spend more on the system that
carries three percent now if that three
percent had been growing if over those
25 years that this has been happening
we've gone from three percent to ten
percent to fifteen percent or something
of the people using that system maybe
there would be something there but what
have we done we have gone from
two-point-nine percent to two point
eight percent so overspending by those
orders of magnitude is actually
decreased at the market share of that
system so there is no amount of money
you could spend on these rail transit
systems that would reverse this decline
and make this make sense so you know for
the children let's actually invest in
the system that carries people in that's
what bombs going to talk about
we had planned this out fight in detail
but this is the best setup I could
imagine for what I'm going to talk about
what I'm now going to turn to is the
highway system primarily and what is
going on in Washington right now this
year that could fundamentally change how
this guy is it on the screen are you
seeing it it's okay so what I'm going to
talk about here it's a summary points
but the federal government is currently
doing in surface transportation which is
mostly highways with some transit and
and this new high-speed rail fantasy is
not at all sustainable the Obama
administration is trying to use this
year's reauthorization of the whole
federal program which only happens about
every six years to make a fundamental
change and enforce drivers by UV to pay
for all sorts of other stuff beer
investments in transit high-speed rail
and so forth and scaling back investment
in highways fortunately we have an
election last fall the house republicans
are seem to be pretty much opposed to
this and are focused on scaling back the
Federal Rule which is exactly the
opposite of the Obama administration's
transportation plan and but a crucial in
this whole debate is that the user users
pay users benefit principle on which
highway funding has been based in this
country since nineteen nineteen when
order enacted the first gasoline tax
specifically as a user charged for
better high risk that is seriously at
risk there are powerful forces trying to
just destroy that principle and turn
gasoline taxes into a general funding
source so first if Adrienne said there's
been all kinds of studies the last five
you
giving up to date figures on how much
we're under investing in the highways on
which most departments and almost all of
our personal travel depend the cost the
interstate highway system through
started under the authorized power in
1956 and completed in mostly in the 70s
and not a bit on the BAS highways even
with proper maintenance typically last
about 50 years and at that point you
really have to rebuild funded will be
down to the sub paid my love and when
you do that your time goes on there's
much better safety standards today
design practices and so for things that
we did in the 50s that no one would
think of doing today because they're not
state-of-the-art design so it makes
sense what you do reconstruct a major
highway to use today's modern standards
and so forth and in many cases you need
to add capacity because the country has
grown a lot since the 1950s in addition
the interstate map the map of what the
network would consist of was drawn up
during World War two for an America that
was largely an industrial economy with
still but with a much larger
agricultural sector in terms of
employment and with cities in the in the
south and the West that were a fraction
of the size of what the thriving
metropolis is are today there is no
interstate if you look the map between
Phoenix and Las Vegas because in during
World War two Phoenix and Las Vegas were
these tiny little cow towns no one saw
any need to connect them with their so
there are selected additions that
actually are needed to make a better
network none of that is in anybody's
serious plans at this point the highway
funding shortfall has been estimated
probably the best most recent estimate
is that at all levels of government
highways and all streets and roads
together just to sustain the current
level of pavement quality level of
bridge repair and so forth and the
performance level not you know it was to
make sure congestion doesn't get any
worse than the horrendous level better
ideas today we should be as a nation
spending in all levels of government
27 billion a year more than birth
spending now it's not a trivial number
to improve conditions to get the backlog
of substandard bridges way down to makes
a significant improvement reductions in
congestion so that travel speeds up we
should be spending about fifty nine
billion a year more now how that's
divided up into federal state logo is a
whole different question but the federal
government is a major player at this
point providing about through federal
gasoline taxes about what it's about
forty percent of the total of all this
money so it's a significant role now
just a quick primer highways are funded
today gasoline taxes as a dedicated
funding sources for highways were
invented in the early part of the 20th
century Oregon as I said passed the
first one in 1919 and over the next 15
years every state every year all other
states passed gasoline taxes in many
cases of they the state constitution was
amended to guarantee that the State
Highway Trust one could only be spent
that user pays money could only be spent
to benefit the highway users only been
to be spent on highways that principle
has been watered down at the state level
over the years but quite a few states
still have a constitutional protection
at the federal level the feds enacted a
one cent per gallon gas tanks in 1932
but it was a general revenue tax it was
not at all dedicated to highways there
was during that same time period
beginnings of a federal aid to highways
program pushed for by the auto clubs and
others but there was no direct
connection with the gasoline tax it was
not a user tax per se dedicated to
highways that change though with the
with the interstate act in 1956 when the
new three-set federal gasoline tax was
enacted specifically to build the
interstate highway system and the
Federal Highway Trust Fund again not
with constitutional protection
unfortunately but dedicated to spending
to build that system and to maintain it
once it was built was created that was
% for those highways now the this
principle the user pays you something
that we at Reason Foundation strongly
believe makes sense the ideal thing
would be toll roads obviously because
that's a even more direct user fee in
the toll can vary more already know the
gassy tax the same whether you're
driving on a two-lane road or at eight
Lane interstate and you know that but I
was cost a lot different so a tolling
system would have higher charges for the
more expensive higher-quality roads and
much lower charges for the others but
still gasoline tax at least as an
approximation of a user pay user benefit
thing as long as the money that's
collected is actually spent on to
benefit highway users it's fair is
proportional to how much you use its
self limiting Europe's gasoline taxes
are not at all dedicated to highways
there a general federal government
national government revenue source
highways have to fight for a budget
allocation like welfare and and you know
government health care and everything
else they get whatever they get and
that's one reason they don't get very
much is why there's so many tomorrow
it's in here because that's the way you
can actually get decent highways despite
paying outrageous gasoline taxes so but
what we've happened since the interstate
you know Congress loves to track votes
by spending money on special interest
projects so every time congress
reauthorized the federal program they
think of something new to spend the
money on so 1970 they added it could be
spent on bus facility both buses used
the road so all right then 1973 they
added rail facilities whoops where what
happen did the users benefit principle
1982 under ronald reagan he agreed to
this historic creation of the mass
transit account in the federal highway
trust fund twenty percent as of nineteen
eighty-two of all the federal gas tax
revenues in its gas and diesel trucks
pay to now ever since goes into the mass
transit account in his grants for cities
to expand and
old bigger and better master at systems
1991 they made two big programs in the
in the overall federal highway program
flexible which means if the state was so
they can divert highway money out of
those accounts into transit in addition
to the transit account that they already
got there's more of that in the
authorizations the next two and today we
did analysis to twelve or twenty five
percent of all highway trust fund monies
are used for non highway purposes and so
that's a significant devaluing of the
users pay users benefit principal at the
federal level and what the
administration has now proposed in their
transportation bill to be debated this
year is basically converting highway
user taxes into general purpose
transportation taxes that would be a
overall transportation trust fund with
what account for highways which would
get less money than they're getting now
another account for mass transit which
would get more money than transit
getting out a whole big new account for
high-speed rail to make it permanent
institutionalized and another one called
an infrastructure fund that could fund
anything that could be called
transportation infrastructure you know
boondoggle waterways projects and then
important projects and again presumably
all paid for by highways although the
administration has not come clean and
said how proposing to more than double
the size of the program without saying
where the rest of the money would come
from it would require adding to the
current 18.4 sent a gallon gasoline tax
would you'd add another twenty six and a
half cents per gallon 22 to fund this
whole thing at the level that they
proposed it and even there within these
smaller about that they dedicate to
highways 27 a half billion of that over
six years would be dedicated to
livability this is what they call of a
highway money not the transit money but
it would go for sidewalks and bike could
make cities denser and require cities to
indict smart growth plans and so forth
so now so that clearly says we need we
need to robust alternative to that
and we've been calling it Plan B and and
and we've been talking for the last year
and a half to house Republicans in
particular and of course now we're
talking to the majority instead of the
minority in that that makes a difference
we say look first thing is to set
priorities federal government is doing
way way too many things in the name of
transportation you need to refocus the
program narrow it way down to what's
truly federal what's truly federal is
interconnections among states so the
interstate system which as I said needs
now that it's more that's becoming 50
years and 60 years old needs to start
being completely reconstructed so as a
crucial need for a big program to do
that and the same principles that we
should be revitalizing restoring the
users pay users benefit principle rather
than what a lot of Transportation saying
let's break down those silos in the
USDOT and make all the money fungible so
that they can hand it out where were
they I think they're going to get the
most political benefits out of it key
Elvis uh Adrian and I have visited with
Jim time and the senior staffer on the
house translation committee who's really
going to be involved in writing the bill
under chairman mica beginning of March
and one of the outcomes of that meetings
is as well why don't you guys put your
heads together and tell us specifically
what provisions would you like to see in
the plan B bill but the House
Republicans will create and pass now
doesn't guarantee they're going to put
them all in but so at the end of March
we send them a memo several page memo
laying out an agenda we said fund the
program at just the level but the gas
tax brings it the existing Gaston if
they've already said no way no how
they're going to vote for an increase in
federal gas tax so live at the size of
program to what existing revenue brings
in completely eliminate the celexa ng
nonsense so that highway money is to be
spent on highways we even said get rid
of the transit funding the transit
account and from that of general that's
not going to happen they're not going to
do that but we we wanted to be true the
principal and say it anyway and
recommend it refocus not trust fund on
the interstates and and maybe on some of
the other major interstate enters the
roads across state borders that carry a
lot of truck traffic
national highway system and because you
can't get the state's more money even
though we know we need a whole lot more
investment in highways give them tools
to leverage money to do tolling and
public-private partnerships that that
are proven to create a lot more value so
we have some numbers this was in a
report Adrian audit last last summer you
could get 11 billion a year more out of
the existing federal gas tax for highway
investment at the federal level if if
you eliminated urban transit and these
enhancement programs is over that or not
and the safety regulation shouldn't be
paid for by highway users all the other
federal regulatory agencies are paid for
out of general revenues so why should
highway users be singled out to have to
pay for highway safety programs then we
try to look at if you had 11 billion a
year more in federal money to invest how
much does that do toward solving the
problem of rebuilding the interstates
well just some some gross numbers here
there's 233 two major bottlenecks on the
interstate system that are mostly in
urban areas like in Los Angeles Los
Angeles has about five of those that are
right near the top in the top 10 or 12
rebuilding all those is about a over a
billion dollar proposition adding reason
did a study about six years ago adding
networks of hot lanes these Express toll
lanes like in Orange County on state
route 91 in the nineteen most congested
metro areas is about 140 billion dollars
that number probably is higher now
because we've had inflation since then
there is no that estimate for completely
reconstructing and modernizing the
interstate system as a whole those two
pieces above that I just gave you 120
839 would be part of that but it's
probably in the ballpark of one to two
trillion dollars so we're clearly going
to need more than the current federal
investment level even if we refocus all
that existing money on highways and
that's why we also need tolling in
public-private partnerships tolling
would be a net new funding source in
addition to the existing gasoline taxes
it's a true user fee you can finance
over a long period of time a long live
asset
highway through towing and and this
would be project finance only it would
not affect the state's bond ratings
because the money would be the a
sadistic the bonds are secured by the
future toll revenues on the specific
highways this would be completely
cashless we no longer need to build we
will never build another toll than
America we're in the process of tearing
them down up get rid of tolls but to get
rid of toll booths and using an entirely
non-stop electronic toll collection and
I think this is a politically feasible
proposition if we add value in exchange
for tolling that value means you do it
for new highways like between Las Vegas
and Phoenix you do it for major capacity
additions to existing highways which
wouldn't exist unless there were the
toll revenue of funding to do it and you
do it when you reconstruct the major
highway which wouldn't happen otherwise
maybe fur to the next 20 or 30 years
well gradually falls apart in each case
you're adding value not saying you get
just continue using the road you're
using now Abbott you're going to pay a
big toll for it no you only pay a toll
if we're adding significant value in
exchange for you're paying the toll
public-private partnerships of course
reason it's as a signature issue for us
for more than 25 years for highways
these long-term private concessions are
especially suited to mega projects
billion-dollar scale projects as Adrian
mentioned with a true private public
partnership of this kind where you have
a money-making proposition unlike
high-speed rail the private sector in
exchange for being able to collect tolls
for say fifty years is willing to absorb
construction risk if it goes over budget
they eat it the completion time risk you
know they they have a big incentive to
get it finished on time because they
can't collect any tolls until the
project is open and cars and trucks of
driving on and it's surprisingly but
importantly the traffic and revenue risk
of brand-new tomorrow it's a very very
hard to predict
how many people are going to use it in
the first five years and so there's a
significant possibility that you will
have less revenue in those early years
than you need to pay the initial debt
service private sector is willing to
absorb those risks to for projects that
make good sense so there's a huge
benefit to doing this and also that
those highways that are funded in this
way it's interesting how the bond market
works if if you want to sell somebody a
toll revenue bond they're going to
insist on covenants in the agreement
that kept their investment the very
first thing they require those
agreements is proper maintenance because
who's going to pay a toll and use a road
if it's not properly maintained over the
long term so that's the very first
priority for you see before the
investors actually get repaid on the
debt service on the bonds the first
dollars go for proper maintenance and
they monitor that they have agents that
monitor that you're doing that so in
just the last two years during the
credit markets crunch we've had four big
toll mega project funded and are under
construction now the United States the
Capital Beltway outside of Washington DC
the 595 project in Florida about a mile
from my house the North carrot express
in Fort Worth and the LBJ project in in
Dallas all these are adding priced
express lanes to existing urban
interstates and you can see the huge
dollar values of that that money is all
all based on the toll revenue financing
now tools uh we had one other idea and
hear that because you know they asked us
what do you guys recommend we do about
transit you know we said first of all
you shouldn't be funny with hi everybody
but since we know it's going to continue
to be federally funded we said the best
thing you could do to is to change the
direction of transit spending from these
boondoggle light rail and heavy rail
projects that attracted tiny fraction of
users for a huge costs instead bus rapid
transit BRT on on hot lanes is an
obvious
cost-effective solution when you price
these new networks of lanes on your
urban freeways and guarantee that their
uncongested at rush hour that gives you
a pathway for express buses to go fast
and reliable in ways that buses that are
currently using the carpool lanes they
get into the same kind of congestion on
corporate ones that we see now so this
could be a real win-win proposition and
I actually had a 45-minute talk
conference with three senior officials
of the u.s. of the Obama administration
do tea last week at their request to
discuss this particular agenda of ideas
and mean they have said yes we're going
to do it but they seemed very very
interested and I followed up with
additional information to request it so
to wrap up and let you ask some
questions this year with the federal
reauthorization the federal
transportation program is at a
fundamental crossroads we have the
administration plan that destroys the
user pays you should benefit concept and
transforms it into a slush fund for all
kinds of other things than needed
highway investment we have an
alternative that we're working to craft
with the House Republican majority I
think we'll get something very much
along the lines of what we are proposing
well that's still being worked on
holding fast to the no gas tax increase
proposition gives us a lot of live to
say all right we've God refocus the
investments on where it makes sense and
not on federal projects to build
sidewalks and bike trails and that but
it's part of this Congress must give the
state's tools to do a lot more with
tolls and public-private partnerships
and I think ladies and gentlemen we've
got a good shot of getting a lot of that
so with that thank you very much and
we're
you